روسيا تعلن عن تدمير سفينتين حربيتين
لاوكرانيا في البحر الاسود فهذا الممر
المائي الهام صار بؤره اساسيه لصراع بين
موسكو وكيف في الاسابيع الاخيره ولا سيما
بعد الانسحاب الروسي من اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه عبر هذا البحر وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه قالت انها دمرت زورق
استطلاع اوكراني كان بالقرب من منطقه
لانتاج الغاز الروسي ثم تحدثت عن تدمير
زورق سريع امريكي كان فيه مجموعه انزال
اوكرانيه قرب جزيره الافعى وفي سياق مواز
تتواصل هجمات الطائرات المسيره في العمق
الروسي الملاحه الجويه توقفت لفتره وجيزه
في مطارات موسكو الثلاثاء الا ان اوكرانيا
تتجنب اعلان مسؤوليتها بشكل مباشر عن هذه
الضربات وروسيا من جانبها تقلل من شان
الاضرار التي تصيب اراضيها وتقلل ايضا من
شان الهجوم العسكري الذي تشنه اوكرانيا
لاستعاده اراضيها في الشرق المتحدث باسم
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قال ان قوات بلاده
احبطت هجمات الاوكراني في كوبيانس
كوزابوريجيا ودانيسك وكريسني ليمان لكن
الرئيس الاوكراني يظهر التفاؤل ويعد
مواطنيه بمزيد من الزخمولا سيما بعد عودته
من جوله اوروبيه وصفها بالمثمره
نعود الى الوطن بدعم سياسي جديد واتفاقات
جديده الجميع شدد على سلامه اراضي
اوكرانيا وسيتم توفير طائرات لنا ومركبات
مدرعه اضافيه فضلا عن تعزيز انظمه الدفاع
الجوي كما تكثف اوكرانيا جهودها لمكافحه
الفساد الداخلي السلطات داهمت 200 مركز
للتجنيد العسكري حيث تقول نيابه العامه
الاوكرانيه انها ستقضي على منظومه فساد
تتيح للمجندين الفرار من الجيش